the movie opens up with a pixelated
video game scene where two characters
are fighting and falling from a height
then it switches to our main character
Chev Chelios falling from a helicopter
and crashing onto a car in the street he
bounces off the car's roof and lands in
the middle of the road near a junction
as soon as he lands a group of Chinese
henchmen quickly pick him up and put him
in a van later when Chev wakes up he's
in a makeshift hospital and he sees
doctors removing his heart right then a
man named Johnny Van enters the
operating room and does something
gruesome he drops ashes from his
cigarette into chev's heart which annoys
the doctors they quickly send Johnny out
of the room and replace chev's heart
with an artificial one to keep him alive
until they can take his other organs it
turns out the doctors are working for
Johnny who is an organ Smuggler after
the heart transplant Chev Falls
unconscious in the next scene a woman
checks his body temperature in a
peculiar way she uses a thermometer
between his legs when waking him up now
let me see oh yes it's very hot down
there after a while Chev overhears two
doctors discussing taking more of his
organs including his private parts this
infuriates him o no one's taking my
balls prompting him to beat up
the doctors he then notices a yellow
battery pack attached to his waist but
keeps it on and leaves the room naked he
wanders around the building until he
finds clothes in a hooker's apartment
what after he puts them on he leaves the
place Johnny's men quickly follow him
outside and point a gun at him however
Chev manages to defeat them with
relative ease this is Stam in his prime
after all he then forces one of them for
information and the guy reveals that
Johnny has his heart he also discloses
that Johnny can be found at the Cypress
Social Club following this Chev enters a
random car hot wires it and sets off to
find his heart while driving to the
Cypress Social Club he starts feeling
weak and notices a warning light on the
battery that's powering his artificial
heart this makes him anxious so he
decides to pull some wires out of the
car and use them to recharge his heart's
battery once he's done the energy
returns and he accelerates towards his
destination during the drive Chev makes
a call to his doctor friend Dr Miles he
then Reveals His predicament of having
an artificial heart and asks for a
solution to keeping it charged this
surprises miles and he explains that
artificial Hearts don't last for long if
the battery runs out Chev will only have
an hour to live miles then advises him
to keep his body charged and find his
real heart as soon as possible as Chev
gets closer to the Cypress Social Club
he encounters two Mobsters who challenge
him to a car race however he refuses The
Challenge and simply asks for directions
to the club unfortunately in a brief
moment of distraction Chev crashes his
car which leads to the loss of his
heart's battery system with no way to
recharge Chev asks the Mobsters to juice
him up juice me up daddies this of
course confuses them but they decide to
comply anyway they follow his
instructions and Chev connects the
jumper wires one to his chest and
another to his tongue surprisingly the
high voltage jolt charges his heart and
greatly boosts his physical abilities he
can now run like a horse after a while
Chev finally arrives at the club at
first he unintentionally rescues a
hooker named Ria from an abusive
customer he then goes inside the club to
find Johnny but the mobster manages to
escape by jumping over the fence
meanwhile Ria becomes smitten with Jeff
as she considers him her protector our
guy tries to ignore her but his interest
is quickly peaked when she claims to
know where Johnny is she then takes him
to a place called the nude girls club
creative inside the club the owner Chico
is violently interrogating Johnny
demanding to know where Chev is at first
Johnny won't talk but when Chico harms
one of his men he speaks up just then
Chev enters the club and sees his
ex-girlfriend Eve performing a pole
dance her character wasn't treated
misogynistically enough in the first one
so they doubled down they share a kiss
but Ria interrupts their moment claiming
that she's chev's new girlfriend this
leads to a fight between the two girls
in which Eve emerges Victorious at the
same time Chico arrives at the scene and
spots Chev delighted he orders his men
to attack and capture him alive however
Chev is not going to give up so easily
he pulls out a gun and a deadly shootout
ensues between the two parties somehow
Chev manages to defeat all of the goons
but Chico manages to escape from a back
door Chev then questions one of the
goons about why their leader wants to
catch him the guy explains that it's not
Chico but another gangster elh Heron who
wants him dead although they don't know
why Furious Chev choots the guy choots
the guy dead and leaves with Eve
unfortunately when he steps outside the
club he's attacked by a group of police
officers you start beating him up during
the fight chev's artificial Hearts
battery drains but when one of the
officers tases him it reach charges
again giving him extraordinary powers he
then fights back and Escapes in one of
the officer cars with Eve unbeknownst to
them there is a hooker in the back seat
apparently hookers are everywhere after
a while Chev uses Eve's mobile phone and
contacts Dr miles to update him on his
situation the latter claims that if he
can find his real heart they can put it
back in his chest at that moment the
hucker reveals that she knows where
Johnny is she explains that he has a box
with him and is likely at the horse race
R ing track at Hollywood Park hearing
this Chev drives towards the horse
racing track I know how to run like a
horse I can find it but unfortunately
finds himself in the middle of a protest
rally led by a group of you guessed it
hookers demanding equal rights
complicating matters another group of
police officers arrives at the scene in
response Chev quickly flees the area
abandoning the car in the next scene he
runs to a nearby park and encounters two
boys who are using an electric collar on
their dog he confronts the boy Bo
accusing them of animal mistreatment
Chev then takes the electric collar and
places it around his own neck to
recharge his heart later the police
arrive to arrest him but the dog attacks
one of the officers giving Chev the
opportunity to escape however he ends up
surrounded by more police officers from
all sides with no further means of
Escape at that moment someone who looks
like chev's late friend kylo arrives on
a motorcycle and stops in front of him
he asks Chev to get on the bike and
drives him away from the police
however this mysterious guy has some
nervous habits and he ends up crashing
the motorcycle because of course he does
after recovering from the crash the guy
introduces himself as Venus kylo's twin
brother he reveals that he's on a
mission to exact revenge for his
brother's death in response Chev says
that he has already taken out everyone
involved in kylo's death except for a
guy named El hiron he then asks him for
directions to the racetrack and heads
there unfortunately as he arrives at the
place his heartbeat starts to Dr drop so
Chev calls his friend for help miles
quickly comes up with a solution and
says that Chev can recharge his heart
through friction this means he has to
rub his skin onto another person I
wonder if he's going to have sex now
Chev follows the suggestion and tries it
on a few people at the racetrack but
faces criticism and push back
fortunately Eve notices him in the crowd
and comes to his Aid they share an
intimate moment on the racetrack while
the crowd cheers them on after Chev is
totally rejuvenated he leaves his girl
and rushes to find Johnny unfortunately
the mobster once again manages to get
away in his car following this when Chev
encounters trouble with the security a
Chinese gangster named Don Kim comes to
his rescue in a limo inside the limo
Chev asks Don Kim about his stolen heart
and the latter explains that a Triad
leader named pun dong has it wow this
movie is from another era he was in
desperate need of a heart transplant and
that is when he found out about chev's
ability to escape death so he paid his
menal AR large amount of money to
retrieve his heart hearing all of this
Chev questions why Don Kim saved him
right now the gangster lets out an evil
grin and reveals that he is actually
going to deliver him to punon dong this
obviously doesn't sit well with our hero
and he ends up killing Don Kim and his
entire Squad after this Chev leaves the
crashed limo and goes to an electric
grid he grabs the high voltage power
supply with his bare hands and recharges
his heart meanwhile Venus calls his
friend Orlando to help track down aliron
on the other hand Chico reports his
failure to aliron who cruy punishes him
by forcing him to cut off his own
nipples no use crying over spilt milk
next while driving Chev spots an
ambulance and jumps in asking the
paramedics for an extra battery to
recharge his heart they managed to find
one and assist him in connecting it
right then Chev spots his enemy Johnny
Vang on the street so he jumps from the
moving ambulance and hides behind a car
in the midst of this Ria tries to get
Chev attention from the other side of
the road but gets hit by a car this
alerts Johnny of the danger and he
attempts to escape however this time
Chev eventually catches up to him and
beats his ass he then takes the red box
from Johnny hoping it contains his heart
however it turns out to be something
else enraged Chev leaves Johnny on the
ground and calls his Dr Miles the latter
who has many underground connections has
received information about the heart he
reveals that the organ was transplanted
into pong through 3 weeks ago and it's
functioning well miles then promises to
help Chev find punon and mentions that
his girls are on the case after the call
Chev tries to get information from
Johnny but Chico arrives and shoots him
to death they then knock Chev
unconscious and put him in a car trunk
meanwhile punong is seen parading around
the city making sure his last days are
the best at One Stop he is approached by
a lovely lady who turns out to be
miles's assistant she cleverly seduces
him and takes him to a secluded house
there miles is waiting for punong ready
to extract his heart in the next scene
Chev is brought to aliron who reveals
that he's the third Verona brother for
some context Chev killed the other two
vonas Ricky and Alex in the first part
this is why aliron is gunning for
Revenge he threatens to kill Chev and
removes his new battery pack but he
wants it to be a spectacle so he takes
him near the pool there Chev sees
Ricky's severed head inside a tank with
machines Al Heron then explains that he
kept his brother alive artificially so
that he can see chev's demise the
gangsters then start whipping him
brutally and almost finish him off but
Orlando Venus and Ria show up in the
neck of time leveling the battlefield in
the midst of the chaos Chev breaks open
Ricky's tank and kicks his head into the
swimming pool but at the same time he
starts slowing down due to low power
when he sees no other Alternatives he
tries to recharge his heart by climbing
an electric pole as soon as he touches
the live wires he gets electrocuted so
so horribly that he is set on fire but
despite this he still manages to beat up
the enemies he also kills eliron and
dumps his lifeless body into the
swimming pool at this moment Ria arrives
and Chev in a hallucinogenic State
mistakes her for Eve and tries to hug
her unfortunately he ends up setting her
on fire causing her to run away in pain
chev's body is still burning and his
face starts to melt regardless he is
full of energy he walks towards the
camera and shows his middle finger
probably to his enemies ni all you
in the final scene Chev is in a severely
deteriorated State and Doc miles tries
to reimplant his heart Eve watches the
procedure and it seems like a failure as
Chev doesn't respond however after
everyone leaves looking disheartened he
miraculously opens his eyes and the
movie ends subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching